please to have back here on the show
finishing up the hour with us from the
athletic and Fox Sports Bruce Feldman
good to see you Bruce what is the latest
on Maryland sir what can you tell me so
they were gonna have a board conference
call this morning from what I was told
it's wrapping up and I don't know if
there's been any change from what I had
just heard from a text from somebody who
should know they said that right now
there's been nothing done and that could
change obviously my hunch is after the
Tuesday press conference that the
investigation was gonna play out that
doesn't mean if DJ Durkin survives the
call today that he's gonna go back on
the sidelines I don't think that's such
a long how can he go back on the
sidelines there now Bruce I mean and
again the president you're referring to
at the Tuesday press conference
president Lowe was remarkable in the
fact that he and the school took
immediate responsibility for what was
happening in this football program with
it took immediate responsibility because
there was a lag time before they
proceeded to have an investigation
here's the issue I think that's worth
putting because I watched the press
conference and for people who are not
Maryland people are like okay that was
refreshing that the president of the
school took responsibility in the face
of probably you know creating more legal
entanglement so I guess that's what was
my way of saying immediate so I I
understand it you're you're being
literal for the timeline I should have
been a little bit more literal why did
they take so long to start the
investigation was this something that
really escalated because there was an
ESPN report talking about this toxic
culture knows a lot about publicity came
down the Todd line you know down the
pipeline did that force their hands the
other thing and I had a long
conversation with a you know Maryland
insider about this last night was where
do they go from here meaning just the ad
and the president do they know you know
I'm probably not gonna keep our jobs in
the face of this let's do the right
thing here Wallace lows in the 70s he's
probably not gonna get another job as a
president let's do the right thing this
is not gonna be money that's gonna come
out of Wallace LOH the President or
damon.evans the ADEs pocket it's gonna
be Maryland who will have to pay this
lawsuit that we think has come in to the
McNair fan
through the McNair family and by the way
what I think was I don't know if I would
call it a game-changer but when though
those parent when Jordan McNair's
parents go on Good Morning America and
they say what they said that he sat in
our kitchen and he said he would take
heart care of our son Durkin DJ Durkin
and he's he's dead
whether DJ Durkin has the head coach you
know he was not at that that workout and
summer workout that's a damning
statement and I don't know how Maryland
could bring da gherkin back just with
that cuz I don't know how you you
explain around that you could talk a lot
about okay
the trainer's really screwed up the
strength coach who we parted ways with
there was there was a real disconnect
there but at the end of the day you're
the head coach and when the the people
whose kids kid has died on your watch
after they said what they said I don't
know how he can how he could cut it
brought back Bruce Feldman here on the
Rich Eisen show look I I hear all the
time hey this programs on the up and up
and we're going the trending upward cuz
we got the right strength coach how many
times do you hear that I hear that a lot
it's not like I got think we got the
great coordinator we got the strength
throw the guys who are they're all off
size and all the ten what the one thing
I've never heard about a strength coach
is somebody's gone rogue that whatever
is put in place by the strength coach
has gotten the check mark from a coach
or is mirroring the culture from the
coach right I'm young I mean look DJ
Durkins words a lot of people brought
them out there was a story that he had
talked about his strength coach and it
was in an article on si.com and that got
trotted out there quite a bit and you
know whether that's fair or unfair I
mean that's that's a hard reality to
escape I think just because of what you
said
Bruce Feldman here on the show what's
the latest for the Ohio State
I mean we're coming up on the the
deadlock deadline which is when what
should be which know this Sunday's
Sunday now the president went on I think
student radio there at Ohio State the
president University and said we're
gonna we're gonna have a conclusion we
have in conclusion
not saying he was walking back with
their own timeline but that's kind of
what it sounded like you know I thought
when they they put out that statement
almost two weeks ago it was basically
okay we're gonna narrow our focus of the
investigation
my hunch on this and it's not not having
inside knowledge of every email or
that's ever been sent about Urban Meyer
internally or zachsmith the fired coach
was that I could see him surviving this
I think he's going to survive it unless
they find something that is pretty
damning because from our understanding
of this story is his boss gene Smith was
the one who alerted him now if his boss
knew and he offend though and the law
knew then what exactly where where was
Urban Meyer's responsibility beyond that
and so while it may be while it may look
bad and smell bad to a lot of people you
know if he's saying he acted
appropriately from protocols and
procedures and if he didn't mislead
anybody I think he's gonna keep his job
well could you cuz you can't fire him
for cause on that front if he did in
fact inform so so Zack Smith has pulled
off the recruiting trail by Gene Smith
and Urban Meyer knows at this point in
time they never reached out to Zack
Smith's wife but we've heard from Sally
that go we're here we're here like the
sides of the story we don't know we've
heard we've heard from the Bruce family
and we've heard from Zack Smith's wife's
mother I mean this has been an absolute
holy heck of a mess that's business but
what and this what we know that's
probably what's in front of these
investigators right now to try and
figure out so if they come back and say
yes Urban Meyer went ahead and said and
and informed and that's why Zack Smith
was pulled off the recruiting trail how
did he keep his job well that that's the
crux of it and then if if it is legit as
to why he kept his job then why did her
band Meyer not say when he was asked
exactly what happened at the media day
coming coming out and saying that yeah
those are some questions that I need to
see answer yeah and a question I would
be curious about is you fired him the
night before it Big Ten media days if
you said nothing
happened legally what was it that caused
you guys to fire him
Herr Meyer said a lot of things he
definitely said more than he probably
for his own benefit should have said
that day not just on the podium at
Chicago in the big 10 meetings but over
the course of the day
so what we don't know is did they
confront Zach Smith with more
information and find out Zach Smith
story didn't match up that he was
dishonest with them and they go okay
this is more trouble than it's worth was
that the decision we don't know what
caused him to fire him we also as you
said you know reading between the lines
from hearing a lot of this I think
there's a lot of people who are gonna
say especially Ohio State people gonna
look at this and go okay well did they
not believe his ex-wife was some of this
did the why did the police not why did
the police not pursue charges we don't
know a lot of things we know what we've
seen from some text message photos but
there's there needs to be more context
to this there's a lot of details we just
don't know at this point but you could
sit here and say man this is a bad look
for Urban Meyer going back to your
original point about not seemingly being
upfront and honest that Big Ten media
days when one of his biggest mission
statements is about honesty no I know
that but one if he's being dishonest
with the media you can't file you don't
get fired for cause and and and you also
don't lose your fan base know everybody
else where where the media is the end of
this being nienna is being called the
enemy of the people I'm serious I'm you
know I'm not trying to you know mix
sports and politics but that is what's
going on in our country today and it's
73 and 8 for his tenure at Ohio State I
think without a doubt and I don't know
any inside information he's gonna keep
this job and I even I even said on the
show the other day I'm gonna bounce this
off you three-game suspension where he
doesn't coach home against Oregon State
home against Rutgers and then at the
Jones Mahal that that game against TCU
he won't coach that one either and
that'll be a tough one for him to knock
coach but it'll be just oh hi Oh state
saying we are gonna take our lumps and
we're gonna
losing football games because it's
important that we sit this coach down
then he returns to a standing ovation at
home and the horse you've beaten the
crap out of Tulane with old respect to
Tulane and then he's ready to roll
against Penn State he'll be there I
would be stunned if he's not on the
sidelines against Penn State here's my
question on that though and you may be
right
but from a crisis management standpoint
what is a three-game suspension do if
you're Ohio State because people are
always gonna say you know with
suspensions it was too lenient right so
what to me a suspension says is you were
kind of wrong here
you were wrong and this is our way to
kind of put a salve on it it to me it's
like a little pregnant you're either we
either found something pretty damning
and you had to go or you know what you
handled this appropriately we don't love
the fact that we should have cut bait on
this this guy with a lot of baggage much
sooner and in hindsight it looks really
bad but she but Urban Meyer acted
appropriately at least by policy and
procedure so suspending them to me I'm
not sure how that helps anything no I
how it helps is he still the coach he's
suspending he's already been out for a
couple of weeks I don't mean to be glib
or or callous unknot he would still be
the coach when it all comes down to it
Bruce if you're talking to how many of
the Ohio State fan base would be so
irate over Urban Meyer still keeping his
job how many so what's the finer they
find if they find what we're assuming
which is no much more no smoking gun
exactly well then I think they're going
to having reported he can't be fired for
cause if there's no lawsuit coming from
urban or somebody else if there was no
title 9 violation with the ultimate of
respect and you could sit here and hear
what we're talking about well what about
the scourge of domestic violence correct
it's awful it's terrible but when you're
talking about a head coach and a program
that's 173 out of 81 games
um I'm being blunt and honest here if
that's what a three-game suspension does
it's terrible maiya culpa
we've punished him he's got that on his
marking record
but he's still a coach but I'm looking
at it saying I'm not I'm not disagreeing
with you I just don't think the
punishment looks like you're really
doing anything no it doesn't I think but
if there's no smoking gun
I think Ohio State fans are gonna look
at and go you know what he was
exonerated because the police didn't
bring charge is and then they're gonna
say because it's really hard for people
to figure out what happens in somebody
else's personal life and they know this
is a really screwed up marriage between
you know the Smiths and now they're not
married anymore and there was a lot of
you know I think it's different if there
were if they find out there were charges
made and then they look the other way
but if there were no charges made I
think people are gonna say well what did
Urban Meyer know and if this is all he
knew and his boss knew about it
could he you know if he's gonna he could
fire anybody he wants by the way you
know he's fight he's forced out other
guys cuz he you know they weren't ideal
fits for what he wanted he could fire
anybody but I think there's gonna be the
the other side of it is gonna say well
you know was he firing him for no reason
because he didn't have a reason because
there were no charges against him the
police never found I mean I think that's
some of the some of what you'll hear and
all the stuff we were talked about about
not being truthful at or being clear or
however you want to say it at Big Ten
media is that stuff will be things that
other people will throw it held about
Ohio State fans I don't think they'll
claim to correct I agree with you let's
take a break that was the Honda inside a
report when we come back quarterback
battles Clemson we have DuBose swinging
on this week I want to know who's
playing quarterback at Clemson I want to
know who is playing quarterback at
Alabama and in other spots that you can
quickly hit that's what Bruce Feldman
when we come back
alright we got about three minutes for
quick hitters Bruce Feldman at Bruce
Feldman cfb a great follow and of course
the Fox Sports so you'll be out there
coming up it's the week we got Texas at
Maryland should be an interesting word
you'll see you're gonna be on the campus
there although the game is actually at
FedEx Field
I mean I mean week one is chock-full of
neutral site contests but Michigan at
Notre Dame is one obviously I've got
that circled Alabama who's gonna be the
quarterback you know it's it I am we're
all guessing at this point because you
have Jalen Hurd's who by the way was
like the SEC Player of the Year as a
freshman but to a man right it was great
in the in the national title game now
somebody pointed that pointed this out
to me to have made a couple of big
mistakes that he got away with in that
game sure big big mistake he took a huge
took a huge sack threw the ball to the
wrong to the wrong person and and one of
the Alabama players rescued him or else
that's a pic you know to is upside you
would think is a lot better the thing I
look at is I don't think anybody's gonna
challenge Alabama until the end of the
year when they play Auburn I mean their
schedule is extremely soft the way this
year they traded FSU for Louisville and
by the way Louisville obviously doesn't
a little more Jackson I don't think
Louisville's all that good
I didn't they're gonna cruise there my
guess is they probably will play both
guys quite a bit huh so in a couple
minutes we have left Clemson who do you
think it's gonna be Kelly Bryant Trevor
Lawrence who do you think Trevor
Lawrence is upside is is so much further
than Kelly Bryant and I think the
consistency issue with Kelly Bryant's a
concern I think ultimately Kelly Brian's
gonna overtake them you know they have
some tough games early on I think they
play am on the road week two that's a
tough place to bring a true freshman I
mean look Trevor Lawrence was there in
the spring knows the offense they got
really good receivers I think they can
win with defense for a while I think
eventually it's gonna be you're gonna be
Trevor Lawrence here in Southern
California who's gonna be I'd be really
surprised if JT Daniels it doesn't run
away with this thing okay you would one
guy Jack Sears who really struggled in
the spring was a talented kid he was Sam
darn old understudy came from the same
school he's really made a lot of
progress and made it more of a battle
but I just don't I just think that they
look and go JT Daniels is gonna be
guy but I think they want it to be a
competition because you don't want the
other two guys or just bail real quick
headers Florida State who do you have
what do you think is gonna be my guess
is diandra France while I'm he's a tough
tough kid and I think he's done a lot of
what Willie Taggarts asked them to do
but I think again you'll see probably
both guys there too and we had a Jew
Jabril Peppers on earlier this week and
I'm like so what tell me what you're
hearing about Jay Paterson he's like
don't sleep on Peters is there is there
really a competition at quarterback
yeah head coach loves competition
questions I've always heard with Peters
is does he have the personality
commanding presence to run the show what
you need to see a lot of a lot more of
from Shape out arson as great as his arm
is really quick-release really athletic
can he be consistent I mean that's the
big big concern well we'll see thanks
for coming on
thanks yet Bruce Feldman here on the
show thanks for being here the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience